all right with Mass Effect 3 coming out
next month we got a prep for it
Mass Effect 2 so I'm going to review
this game under the assumption that if
you're watching a review from Mass
Effect 2 you have played Mass Effect 1
alright so at the end of Mass Effect 1
depending on how you played the game a
few different things could have happened
generally speaking a Reaper named
sovereign attacked the Citadel and you
stopped him what are the Reapers you
asked I will tell you they're a sentient
race of immortal machines hell-bent on
destroying the entire galaxy
but you Commander Shepard will stop them
so one last effect to Commander Shepards
been out of commission for a couple of
years and the intro leading up to that
is one of the coolest things I've played
in the game it just took me by surprise
I was like I did not expect that to be
that cool in that cinematic and that
epic thank you Mass Effect 2 for being
you two years later commander shepard is
now working with Cerberus Cerberus is an
independently funded organization they
did some really seedy experiments they
were pretty much one of the bad guys in
the first game and you stopped them a
few times now you're kind of working for
them because they're the only ones who
are like yes we have the budget to help
you out and unlike the Alliance we see
that there is a Reaper threat and so now
you got to scour the galaxy and get a
crew together when I first saw this
premise when I was playing Mass Effect 2
I was like I liked my crew from the
first game I don't want a new crew you
do get a couple of people from Mass
Effect 1 that are on your crew and Mass
Effect 2 but there are a few that aren't
so it kind of feels incomplete at first
you're like I don't like this but this
crew grows on you these guys are awesome
it just seems like you have more
intimate dialogue with your crew when
you're talking to him you kind of get to
know them more I mean you got to know
them in the first one it just seems in
this game it's on a more personal level
it might be because and this is one of
my favorite aspects of Mass Effect 2
every crew member has a loyalty mission
that you have to do for them so that's
something I like in Mass Effect 2 over
Mass Effect 1 another thing I liked over
Mass Effect 1 is the weapon system in
Mass Effect 1 you had unlimited ammo in
Mass Effect 2 you have ammo
however in Mass Effect 1 your gun would
overheat until the end of the game it
would overheat pretty fast especially
when you're using sniper rifles in Mass
Effect 2 you don't allocate your level
points to weapons your weapons get
stronger because you find weapon
upgrades throughout the game which means
when you use the sniper rifle it's a
steady sniper scope from the beginning
so I like the fact that you can use the
sniper rifle from the beginning of the
game in Mass Effect 2 and not feel like
you're Michael J Fox playing Sniper Wolf
and Metal Gear Solid or something and
your weapon mods okay let's say you
wanted a mod on your weapon in the first
Mass Effect you
had to go into that specific weapon and
modify it and you had to do that for
every character everything every weapon
it was really annoying in this game it's
just an ability your ability menu opens
up you're like oh that mod now I have it
it's really quick it's really fast it's
like one button modding some people said
they hated it because they felt it took
away from the RPG aspect of Mass Effect
I felt it added to the fun aspect
because the last time you're spending
micromanaging your weapons the more time
you're spending doing anything else and
all around in Mass Effect 2 the
dialogues been refined just the way you
run looks better the camera gets a
little shaky behind you just looks a
little more real if you have a
miscellaneous mission that you're going
down to on a planet it's not a
cookie-cutter base like it was in the
first one every planet is different and
mining ore is a lot better in Mass
Effect 2 Mass Effect 1 you have to take
this Land Rover thing and go down to the
surface and this thing's like going up
hills upside down it sucks ass and - you
scan the planet and shoot probes and now
you have ore and you're getting money
and you can upgrade your stuff on the PC
version it's great on the Xbox 360 on
the PC the scanner goes as fast as you
can move your mouse you're scaling that
planet and you're fine 360 it goes
really slow as though
my friend was watching me is like you
can get an upgrade to make it go faster
I was like this is the upgrade that
makes it go faster this is as good as it
gets and word from the wise I'm just
saying this is a tip if you're talking
with someone go Paragon or renegade go
extremely nice or extremely dick don't
go in the middle because you're not
going to get the Paragon or renegade
points that you want when I say want I
mean need because there are point in the
game where you're gonna have to defuse
some conflict among your teammates if
you don't have your dialogue up in one
way or another it's not going to get
diffused again be nice or be a dick in
knowing by the end of the game I'm gonna
have to have a full Paragon a renegade
bar I feel like I'm not free to just
interact with people how I would
interact it's like oh I'd like to be a
little more harsh on this guy but I need
Paragon points for that one conflict
that's coming up so I mean I'm gonna be
nice I don't like that I'd like to be
free to do whatever chaotic neutral I
guess that's what you'd call it can't be
that when playing Mass Effect I guess in
the end love the characters love the
gameplay love the graphics they beefed
that up big time love the crew and I
love the end by the end of Mass Effect 2
anyone
and everyone can die on your crew
including you so you got to be a good
commander in the end mission if you pick
wrong if you haven't done what you need
to do throughout the game people could
die and when they die they're not in
Mass Effect 3 that's a really cool
aspect I mean you see in Mass Effect 2
things that you did in one do tie into
two so I can only imagine where they're
taking three I mean I can't wait to see
that and yes one of the aspects of Mass
Effect are the romances and I got to say
Miranda in Mass Effect 2 probably one of
the hottest game chicks of all time
she's voiced by and modeled after the
chick from Chuck so there is that my
favorite crew member though I got to say
tally
I mean tally was in one and tallies in
two tallies loyalty missions one of my
favorites you just feel protective of
tally you like tell your liked ally
you're a good person
miranda is so hot so I would say get
Mass Effect 2 steam always has absurd
deals I got Mass Effect 1 & 2 for like 7
bucks each completely worth it Mass
Effect 2 is a blast and it sets the
stage for Mass Effect 3 so have you
played the Mass Effect games what did
you think of them comment below let me
know and are you gonna get Mass Effect 3
because yes I am and yes I will do a
video on it in any case if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you can find like a chrome in the run
but you never be
Commander Shepard